Now once again let's think about the semantics of RPC.
The client has made the call and the client is
blocked and since the client is blocked, we don't need
to buffer the message on the client's side. If the
message gets lost for some reason, you don't hear back
the result of the RPC from the destination, in a
certain amount of time, you can resend the call, from
the client side. And therefore you don't have to buffer
the client side RPC message but it can
reconstruct the client side message and resend the call.
Therefore client side buffering is something that you
can get rid of, once again, because the LAN
is reliable. The next source of overhead, similar
to client side buffering, happens on the server side,
and that is the server is sending the
results and the results may get lost. LAN reliable
may not happen that often but it could happen
,and therefore we do want do the buffering. On
the server side because if we don't buffer it
then you have to reexecute the server procedure to
produce a result and that's not something that you
want to do because it involves reexecuting the server procedure
which may be much more latency intensive then simply
buffering the packet that corresponds to the result of
executing the server procedure so you do want to buffer
on the server site but. The buffering on the
server side can be overlapped with the transmission of
the message. So in other words the result has been
computed by the server procedure. Now go ahead and
send the result. While you are sending the result back
to the client, do the buffering. That you can
overlap the service side buffering with the result transmission, and
get it out of the critical path
of the latency for protocol processing. So, removing
low level asks, employing hardware check sum and
not doing check sum in software. Eliminating client
side buffering all together. And overlapping the
server side buffering with the result transmission are
optimizations that you can do. In protocol processing,
recognizing that the LAN is reliable and therefore
we don't have to focus so much on
the reliability of message transmission. But focus rather on
the latency, and how we can reduce the
latency, by making the protocol processing lean and mean